from you
or what are the best and most memorable
lyrics you've ever written
wow that's a hard question for me the
stuff stand out like stuff you're really
proud of that was like
important in your career
yeah i i i mean
i think i did a song called sun sun
shower i don't know if it we put it on
the wu tank forever double cd but only
on the international version
but
if anybody could go get those lyrics and
write those lyrics down you could just
put that in your pocket and i'm sure
that it'll answer at least about 25
percent of your life's problems
uh well there's a good one uh sunshine
where you talk about religion and god
that's that's good so i think it's on a
diagram
i'm not a record guy yeah i'm a song i
might have been a diagram what do you
have a lyric for me yeah the answer to
all questions you're talking about god
yeah
the spark of all suggestions of
righteousness the pathway to the road of
perfection who gives you all and never
asks more of you the faithful companion
that fights every war with you
before the mortal view of the
prehistorical historical he's the all in
all you're searching for the oracle yeah
this is such a this is so good a mission
impossible is purely philosophical but
you can call on your death bed when
you're laying in the hospital you will
call them on your deathbed i had a big i
have a scientist friend
well my wife's best friend rebecca
uh
she married a sign they both signed it
they both were scientists and she
married uh dr neil
i
i don't even say their last names
but neil and rebecca you know you know
my white best friend so they come over
and me and neil we go through the
longest
debates of science and religion we just
go we break we could go break day with
it
and
you know before he had a child
he was more adamant
and
you know there's you know i don't
believe in god you know what i mean
after a child he still kept his thing
but i just hit him with the question if
you was about to die because now you got
a child to take him out right he's
different when you're thinking about
yourself i asked asking if he's about to
die
do you you don't think you're going to
make that call he's like i'll make that
call
and it kind of inspired my lyric because
it was like yeah who you gonna yeah and
i just want to say as far as so you
mentioned lyric that is one of my
favorite lyrics but that's part two
to
sun shower was the uh prequel to
sunshine
yeah so if you ever get a chance to
check out sun shower
uh it starts off with trouble follows a
wicked mind 2020
vision of the prism of life but still
blind because you lack the inner
so every sinner could end up in the
everlasting winter of hell fire
but thorns and splinters prick your eye
out you cry out your words fly out but
you remain unheard
suffering
internal
and external along with the wicked
fraternal of generals and colonels
landlord thermal nuclear heats that
burns you firmly and permanently
upon the journey through the journal of
the book of life
but those who took a life without
justice will become just ice
it's been taught your worst enemy
couldn't harm you as much as your own
wicked thoughts
but people ought to be naught and listen
wrought
so they find themselves persecuted
inside their own universal court
so that it's a long one that's like a
three-pager wow that is about life
that's like character integrity how to
be
yeah how to be in this world and that
ultimately connects to god
you